it's nice to finally get a chance to
talk with you I obviously want to talk
about the draymond Green kick and no
suspension in a little bit but I'm going
to start with last night's game and the
Raptors Cavs series how surprised are
you by what's happening and what took
place the last two games in Toronto well
I'm surprised from the standpoint it
just the abrupt turn around that the
Raptors made once they got back to
Canada particularly with the Marga Rosen
and Kyle Lowry I mean they are playing
the way that you know they have that
proved themselves to be all stars
throughout the season but it was what
was evident to me is that when they're
in that building with that kind of
energy with that crowd there a different
ballclub I think for the Raptors you
know getting the kinds of performances
are getting defensively from guys like
this Mac be ombo but their entire team
and the amount of deflections that they
have are able to get out on the break
they're pushing the basketball look like
a completely different team to me than
the one we saw in Cleveland so it's
going to be interesting here on out as
to whether or not they can sort of
duplicate that kind of energy and effort
on the road which they're going to have
to be Cleveland on the road if they
expect to win the series yeah I mean as
a football guy I love the physicality
and the energy that the ambos bringing
and conversely i gotta tell you is two
very disappointed in Kevin Love the last
two games in Toronto I mean they talk
about the big three I don't know how
Cleveland can win the NBA Finals I get
where they want to go with him playing
like this ya know I'd have to agree with
you and it surprises me that some people
will say that lebron is now so right
surrounded by the best supporting cast
that he's ever had and to your point i
don't think that the you know the
threesome of a bra and Kyrie Irving and
Kevin Love even compares to LeBron
Dwyane Wade and Chris Bosh during the
time that they won their championships I
totally disagree with that I just
thought that that other crew in my
me you know maybe not quite as talented
if you factor in Kyrie who I think it's
a supremely talented guard but just
their their approach their mental
toughness their willingness to sacrifice
and understand the roles of each the
other players on that Miami team to me
doesn't compare to this Cleveland team
now perhaps the Cleveland team the
Cavaliers this edition will grow to
understand that and develop that but
it's obvious to me that they haven't
quite yet and question themselves
talking with Stu Jackson TV analyst for
NBA TV prior to that obviously a team
executive head coach but also the VP of
basketball operations the role that Kiki
Vandeweghe has the discipline guy
basically which by the way I was blown
away we're gonna net momentarily but
reading Kiki's report about private
investigators everything that goes into
it I'm like floored by that let's start
stew with the with the draymond play
because i guess i saw on twitter where
you said you thought he should have been
suspended yeah i did you know i thought
he should be suspended for a variety of
reasons one is I was really intrigued by
the release at the NBA you know put out
where it mentioned that dream on flailed
well that's sort of a half-truth he
flailed with his arms but when he was
stationary on the floor he then kicked
after the flail with his arms and that
kick you know delivered a blow to the
groin that I thought was really severe I
was severe enough to drop atoms to his
knees it was clearly the wind up with
the leg to follow through a high
potential for injury when you kick
somebody in that area that hard and you
know I just thought Adams was in a
vulnerable position and couldn't defend
himself so you know for that reason when
you add up those factors that meet the
criteria for a flagrant foul and you
look at how hard he was kicked III
thought he should have been suspended
now listen there have been times when
you
players have been hit in the groin where
they haven't been suspended but they're
in the minority for sure most times we
look through the history of discipline
in the NBA when a player hits another
player in the groin generally he's going
to suffer a one-game suspension well I
don't understand stew is that you see
all these videos on Twitter of draymond
flailing all the time and kikis been
pretty outspoken that well this is just
something that draymond does a lot he
flails trying to get foul calls who says
that's okay I mean who says that that
makes it okay it's like because I throw
my elbows a lot it's okay if I connect
one time on someone's jaw because I do
it a lot that I don't understand the
logic there Stu well there's there's not
much logic that I can see because listen
and I acknowledge players flail all the
time but we also happening now is when a
player fails what he's trying to do is
bring attention to some contact that he
feels he's absorbed and bring that
attention to the referee essentially
he's flopping so now we're saying that
you have the ability to flail / flop and
in the process if you hurt someone else
that that's okay while you're trying to
deceive the game it makes no sense you
know to me at all and then you know
furthermore when you go and review those
flagrant fouls as they did yesterday you
know post game and they do go through a
very extensive process of investigation
and talking to players talking to the
referees talking to internal you know
staff to try to assess you know as best
they can all the information that they
have but when you go through that
process and you upgrade to a flagrant
foul penalty to you know the team that
really gets cheated is the Thunder
because the flagrant foul penalty to
calls for an automatic ejection so now
the Thunder have not been advantaged by
greens absence on the floor he stayed in
the game you know after the flagrant
foul and now he you know he doesn't
suffer the penalty of not playing
subsequent into that and still is going
to play in game 4 just seems a little
bit unfair how involved is the
Commissioner in these decisions I know
you made these decisions for a long time
how involved is the Commissioner it was
David Stern with you obvious
silver now well to be clear you know and
uh I my job and kikis job is to make
recommendations to the commissioner
ultimately he is the key decision-maker
and he's the key decision-maker why
because these things matter fans care
about them you know a decision one way
or the other can affect the NBA bran or
affect you know the perception of
integrity in the game it's a pretty big
deal and the Commissioner should be
making those decisions and you know when
I was a part of the NBA I made those
recommendations to David Stern and yes
more times than not he accepted my you
know recommendation but he has the right
and it's his prerogative to say no you
know Stu or Adam in the case of kiki no
that's not the way we're going to go so
at the end of the day you don't know you
know what Kiki Vandeweghe recommendation
is and and and but ultimately that
decision rests with the Commissioner
when you looks to what happened with
Dante Jones and now what happened with
draymond Green is it fair to say that
there's a a different standard for star
players in the NBA well I mean to be
clear the doctor Jones you know was a
pretty bright line rule in that you know
he basically took a little flick or a
little swing and hit beyond bow in the
groin and the rule clearly says if you
do that whether you have a closed fist
or and opens this contact or not because
you're going to suffer an automatic
one-game suspension so in that regard
it's different but clearly if you look
at you know the way that physical
contact has been evaluated throughout
these playoffs you know it leads you to
a notion that there is a little bit of a
double standard and case in point you
know Durant flagrant foul penalty to
where he took justin anderson Ted off
Isiah Thomas where he swung and he hit
Schroeder in the head you've got now the
you know the draymond Green situation
there was another non call where another
star player hits another star player
Andre Drummond hits you know LeBron
James in the head clearly the standard
is in playoff games they want to keep
these better players in the game
and you know not not suspend them for
the next one which is again okay that's
fine but then don't have the rule
written that calls for an automatic
suspension in these cases cases rewrite
the rule and let everybody know what
that rule is so the NBA is not in a
situation where they leave everything to
chance and leaves people wondering
exactly where the line is so here's what
I understand those two because you just
said if you look at what's happened so
far this postseason it would lead you
believe there is a double standard for
star players still you did this right i
mean you were the one that made these
decisions with the commissioner for a
while so you would know whether or not
there's a double standard right i mean
what what what took place when you were
the one doing it well listen you know
what took place is is that we tried to
be very consistent treat all players
equally because we felt it was important
to the integrity of the game and that
was never more exemplified and listen
you can debate this and people will for
maybe perhaps another decade what we did
in 2007 in the San Antonio Phoenix Sun
series were resuspended Boris BL and
Amar'e Stoudemire for leaving the
vicinity of the bench during an
altercation where they left 20 you know
they were 25 feet away from the bench so
listen that was a very difficult
decision it was painful but the decision
was made in the interest of consistency
and integrity because there's a rule on
the books that says you have to suffer
an automatic one-game suspension doesn't
matter if it's a playoff it doesn't
matter who the player is and they were
two integral players in that series and
yes it did change the course of the
series unfortunately for the Phoenix
Suns who I thought competitively was a
better team at that time than the San
Antonio Spurs but you had to do what you
had to do because it's a rule and so you
have a rule you enforce it if you're not
going to enforce it don't have the rule
just to really appreciate the time
thanks for coming on this morning no
happy to do it right all right good to
talk with Stu Jackson first time get a
chance to talk to a guy that is a legend
in my hometown of
Pennsylvania the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience